hey what's up guys mkbhd here welcome to
update 8.0 and i never really talk about
my personal life in my videos but uh
here goes so you might have seen me wear
this shirt in one or two of my videos or
this one right here or this one
devil delaware valley youth league it's
an ultimate frisbee team
there i said it so in less than 20 hours
i will be on a plane with the rest of
the team to minnesota of all places for
the youth national championships in the
united states when i get back from that
after a short break i'll be moving into
my new apartment because school's
starting back up and yes there will be a
tour of that so thumbs up for that i
know you guys keep asking yes i will be
getting to a tour of that just let me
get my stuff together while i'm away for
the next week or so i'm going to be
reading through the comments that are
below this video as for suggestions for
the next couple videos that i put out
basically if there's a particular gadget
you want to see reviewed or two things
you want to see put head to head in a
verses or a particular topic you want
explained be sure to leave that in a
comment down below this like button on
this video and i will be going through
those and picking the highest rated ones
and the most popular ones as the next
videos that i produce so if you happen
to like a comment particularly much that
you want to see a video be sure to give
that comment a thumbs up so it'll rise
to the top of the highest rated comments
and i'll see those also with the newest
rollout of the slightly different
youtube home page with the larger
thumbnails and the pins on the side you
might want to make sure you have the
mkbhd channel pinned so you make sure
you have uh my channel name pinned to
the left hand side of your youtube
homepage but i have to start packing so
i'll leave you with a highlight reel of
the last ultimate frisbee tournament
that i played in which was the d3
college national championships here's a
quick preview of that
that's all you get but there's a link in
the description to watch the entire 8
minute video in other news there is a
huge giveaway coming up for the mkbhd
channel so make sure you're following me
on twitter and again like i said make
sure you have me pinned so you're first
to know about this and the information
surrounding it it's gonna be pretty
exciting stuff either way i gotta finish
packing now i've got some stuff to take
to minnesota to make sure i uh
play my best either way
i'll talk to you guys in the next video
and make sure you leave your comments
suggestions down below looking forward
to reading through those take care guys
peace
[Music]
you